Here at It’s Lit it could be misconstrued
that we are just Ivory Tower Literary Elites
with great hair, but the truth is … we are
that, but we’re nerds too.
In the past few decades literature has expanded
to not only mean the “novel”, but “graphic
novels” as well.
Today we are gonna break down how the graphic
novel went from the comic book store to the
classroom.
Narrative art that tells stories has existed
in some form since before civilization.
From cave paintings, to Egyptian hieroglyphics,
to English serialized engravings.
And then we got COMICS!!
But the first big precursor to the graphic
novel is thought to be Histoire de M. Vieux
Bois, drawn by Swiss artist and writer Rodolphe
Töpffer in 1828.
Topffer used sequential imagery accompanied
by text to tell the story of the titular Monsieur
Vieux Bois’s comic misadventures.
By 1841, unauthorized English translations
of Topffer’s work had made their way to
the United States under the title “The Adventures
of Obadiah Old Buck”.
Topffer, in the note to Mr Jabot wrote:
“This little book is mixed in nature.
It is made up of a series of pictures [...] each
one of which is accompanied by a line or two
of text.
The pictures without the words would only
have a very obscure meaning, while the text
without the pictures signifies nothing at
all.
The whole taken together is a kind of novel.”
….a…
GRAPHIC one
While mostly forgotten to modern audiences
now, comics theorist Scott McCloud has called
Topffer the “father of the modern comic,”
"cartooning and panel borders" along with
"the first interdependent combination of words
and pictures seen in Europe"
Broadly speaking, a graphic novel is a collection
of related comic strips that form a story
and are all published together as one book.
Back in the day what really separated comics
from graphic novels was the higher quality
format of the book itself.
Better paper and being bound rather than stapled.
Surrealist painter German Max Ernst is credited
with creating the proto-graphic novel.
In what was called the “Collage novel”
Ernst would take images from other publications
and link them together with a narrative.
American Cartoonist, Milt Gross, published
the pantomime tale He Done Her Wrong: The
Great American Novel and Not a Word in It
— No Music, Too, in 1930 a “wordless novel”
that many consider another precursor to the
graphic novel.
While not super popular it was impactful in
the industry and was a huge influence on Osamu
Tezuka aka “the God of Manga” so like
super niche.
These “wordless novels” were part of the
German Expressionist movement of the early
20th century that were killed off in its nation
of origin following the rise of Nazi censorship
in Germany.
However, it’s influence already gave birth
to the artistic idea that would become the
“graphic novel.”
Now, you might be asking, “Princess, why
not use the word “comic” or “comic book”
instead of “graphic novel?
It sounds like the same thing to me.
And--well--you’re not necessarily wrong;
the term “graphic novel” is a fairly nebulous
one that artists, writers, critics, and fans
have debated over the last few decades, but
we’ll get into that momentarily.
The term was originally coined in 1964 comic
fanzine called Capa-Alpha, by Richard Kyle
but it didn’t take off as a popularized
term until Will Eisner wrote A Contract with
God and Other Tenement Stories.
Sara J. Van Ness it was shared that:
When he first proposed the book to a New York
publisher, Eisner recalls, “A little voice
inside me said, ‘Hey stupid, don’t tell
him it’s a comic or he’ll hang up on you.’
So I said, “It’s a graphic novel.”
Eisner’s intuitive hesitation in labeling
his work as a comic book suggests that he
was conscious of some negative implications
that the comic book label carried.”
This collection of four stand-alone stories
was something Eisner intended for “adults”
and wanted to be published in bookstores.
On the trade paperback of the title it said
“graphic novel.
Making it the “first” of that mainstream
label.
Contract was not the first graphic novel;
many cite Jack Katz’s The First Kingdom,
which came out a few years before Contract,
but what it did was elevate the term “graphic
novel” and comics as a long-form but contained
storytelling device into the mainstream.
This was because Eisner worked to get it stocked
in actual bookstores, validating it’s literary
value in the eyes of adult readers.
Following Contract we had titles like Sabre
by Don McGregor and artist Paul Gulacy, which
takes place in the year 2020 where “Earth
has succumbed to global famine, energy crises,
a plague based on a leaked American-government
bioweapon” … huh…
But this is when we began to see the “prestige”
division between “super serious” graphic
novels and comics.
Titles like Batman: Year One, Sandman, and
The ‘Nam all serve to elevate the way readers
saw the medium.
Sandman is especially notable because as Joe
Sutliff Sanders, a specialist in children's
media at the University of Cambridge, explains,
“Sandman did not create the market for ongoing
graphic-novel series, did not even exactly
drive it, but it did demonstrate to readers,
vendors, distributors, publishers, and writers
that the future of comics lay not in monthly
serials but in bound collections.”
Look, as a nerd who loves comics, I don’t
view graphic novels as inherently “superior,”
but anyone whose read Fables or Saga can tell
you how a good long comic book run can nourish
the soul.
Yes, it is cool when one artist team creates
a powerful stand alone story, but just because
it’s long doesn’t mean it’s good.
Which is just solid advice in general.
The major moment for graphic novels came in
1992 when I was born—and when Art Spiegelman’s
Maus became the first (and is still the only)
graphic novel to win a Pulitzer.
Noted for using postmodernism expression by
representing Jews as mice and Germans as cats,
the story depicts Spiegelman interviewing
his father about his experiences as a Polish
Jew and Holocaust survivor.
Professor of German and Jewish Studies.
PhD, University of Virginia, Erin McGlothlin
explains that:
“Within the field of Holocaust Studies,
Maus is considered a key literary text by
the scholarship on testimony and trauma [...] In
the cultural sphere of comics, on the other
hand, it is celebrated chiefly on account
of its format, narrative, and graphic innovation
and its inventive approach to subject matter
previously deemed unsuitable for the comics
medium.”
Maus is now taught in schools along with titles
like Persepolis by Marjane Satrapi, which
depicts her childhood up to her early adult
years in Iran during and after the Islamic
Revolution.
Persepolis has been subsequently praised as
a postcolonial text.
As Matthew P. McAllister and Stephanie Orme,
wrote in “Cinema’s DIscovery of the Graphic
Novel: Mainstream and Independent Adaptation”
for Cambridge Press:
“Instead of depicting Iranian women as universally
oppressed and as in need of Western liberation,
Persepolis offers a more complete, nuanced
view of Iranian women’s lives--as actively
resisting what they consider “oppressive”
on their own terms.”
Through this we began to see the memoir graphic
novel really emerge as a powerful storytelling
device for coming of age stories.
Craig Thompson explores his upbringing in
an Evangelical Christian family and eventually
leaving Christianity in Blankets.
2006’s Fun Home: A Family Tragicomic by
lesbian cartoonist Alison Bechdel, details
her childhood struggles with gender identity
and childhood abuse.
It was later turned into a musical that ended
up taking home the Tony Award for Best Musical.
Justin Hall explains: “Fun Home was an important
moment for queer graphic novels, both because
of its reception by the mainstream literary,
academic, and cultural establishments and
because of how it helped push the comics industry
to pay more attention to LGBTQ material.”
These stories created the foundation for many
younger cartoonists and illustrators to tell
stories using this longer comic book form.
Especially now, with independent comic publications
outside of the big two (DC/Marvel), places
like First Second Books and others have really
allowed stories to shine.
Queer creators like Noelle Stevenson known
for Lumberjanes and Nimona and Tillie Walden
(Spinning) have used the format to tell engaging
stories that highlight that comics are not
and have never solely been a format for cis-white
hetero dudes.
Jen Wang, writer of Stargazing and The Prince
and the Dressmaker and works by Raina Telgemeier
have entered schools as well, which gives
students new avenues to explore literature
made for them.
Reducing graphic novels and comics in general
to an inferior artform because it’s primary
audience isn’t always adults is just baseless
snobbery.
Storytelling doesn’t belong to any one format
and what makes a book literary isn’t just
that there are words on a page—it is what
stories are being told and how it speaks to
the human experience.
For some of us it’s Grant Morrison’s All-Star
Superman instead of …(checks high brow list)
Infinite Jest.
So for certain authors who think Graphic Novels
aren’t books … well you are wrong.
Kathryn Strong Hansen writes “In Defense
of Graphic Novels”:
“Many teachers have shown how graphic novels
can help energize students whose interests
are hard to capture, can aid low-level and
nonnative English-speaking readers through
the twinning of words with images, and can
challenge higher-level readers to expand their
analytical skills to include consideration
of visual elements.”
The only people who are still dismissing Graphic
Novels are frankly out of touch and maybe
the issue is your own limited idea of what
literature is, not that Superman is in it.